mike sandra for more on this let's bring
in tom homan fox news contributor and
former acting ice director tom welcome
thanks for having me your reaction to
bill's reporting about this saudi
national captured in the yuma sector
wearing an ems uniform from upstate new
york look i'm not surprised i mean i've
been saying all year long when you open
the border to illegal immigration like
the buy administration does
half the board patrol is no longer
patrolling the line they're processing
family groups in facilities so when half
the bore patrol is not on the line
that's when the fentanyl comes through
that killed over 100 000 people that
this year and that's when criminals and
gang members come across and certainly
i've said all along that is vulnerable
to terrorists coming across that country
border patrol has already arrested over
15 on the fbi screening database so out
of the 600 000 that they didn't catch
they got aways this year 600 000 how
many of them were known as suspected
terrorists because terrorists don't turn
themselves over to the border patrol
they're trying to get away that's the
scary thing how many of the 600 000
people enter this country to do us harm
texas governor greg abbott is tired of
waiting for washington to take more
action at the border take a listen to
this
this unprecedented action is needed for
one single reason
and that's because the biden
administration has failed to do its job
as required by the constitution as
required by laws passed by congress to
enforce the immigration laws of the
united states of america
is this the new reality a state
enforcing the federal government's
border well first of all i agree with i
think the president and secretary
mayorkas have violated their all to
enforce laws this country and protect
their sovereignty but you know god bless
governor abbott i mean he should be the
secretary of homeland security because
he gets it he obviously has looked at
the data that shows every place a wall
or barrier has been built illegal
immigration declined illegal drug flow
declined that is a fact that that is
clear on the cbp website so walls work
the buy administration is ignoring that
data and they're not building a wall
simply because it's it's related to
trump somehow but let me be clear
governor abbott's doing the right thing
every mile of wall will result in
decreased illegal immigration decreased
drug flow less women being sexually
assaulted less children dying walls will
save lives at the same time helping to
protect this country let's put some
numbers on the screen border encounters
in the month of november
173 3620
that's up from 164 753 in october
how do you assess those numbers tom the
numbers continue to be historic numbers
november was the highest november in
history this nation the 1.6 if they say
1.6 i think it's 1.9 because they're not
given all the data that's available
we had more illegal immigration this
year under president biden than we've
had in the history of this nation in the
history u.s border patrol they took the
most secure border i've seen in my 35
years where illegal immigration was at a
35 year low and within nine months
total reverse that may made it the most
vulnerable border i've seen in my career
record numbers went from record low
numbers to an historic high and what's
really disturbing is that is on purpose
they they they ran on open borders they
implemented open borders they destroyed
every policy the trump administration
put in that worked this is open borders
this is what we're dealing with you
can't tell me one thing this
administration has done to slow the flow
everything they're doing about how quick
can we release people how quick can we
release people show me one enforcement
action they've taken to slow the flow
there's none
former acting ice director tom homan
thanks very much sandra